okay so a fist fight almost broke out in
the senate in in one of the hearings
today and Bernie Sanders ruining all my
fun we had two adult men agreeing to a
mutual combat situation and Bernie
Sanders starts yelling like you are a
United States Senator sit down and like
you know he's yelling at him and then uh
no kidding this really happened I
definitely want to talk about it and
then we had um probably the more
important story is Kevin McCarthy
physically attacking a who voted against
him uh this rep brette says that he was
elbowed a straight kidney shot and Kevin
McCarthy is trying to backway like I was
just walking through the hall and I
bumped into him that's all that happened
and these reporters are like dude the
hallway is massive how do you
accidentally bump into a guy in the
hallway like No One Believes you plus a
reporter from NPR watched it happen